Los Angeles is now coming together
to confront the greatest
moral and humanitarian crisis
of our time.
Let me be clear once again, we
are here to end homelessness.
Five years after Los Angeles
voters approved tax increases
to raise one and a half billion dollars
to address the region's
homelessness problem,
there are more people living
and dying on the streets
than ever before.
Many of these men and women
are both frequent targets
and perpetrators of violence.
The mayor who did not respond
to our interview request
has partially blamed this
failure on the pandemic,
which slowed new housing construction,
and limited shelter capacity.
It's true that COVID caused
a certain homelessness,
but the city's plan was already failing.
In 2019, homelessness
spiked 13% in LA County.
This was happening way before
the pandemic, trends popping up
places that we didn't see it before.
It's just getting worse and worse.
Think about any city that
has 70,000 displaced people
on the streets, it's unprecedented
and it needs an emergency response.
Everybody's looking for the
next position of their career
rather than focusing on the task at hand.
The centerpiece of LA's plan
was to spend the $1.2 billion
building 10,000 supportive
housing units over a decade.
Even if the city were
able to pull that off,
it would merely put a dent in the problem.
A new housing project
opened in Los Angeles
as one of the first under measure HHH.
We will see an opening
of one of these about
every three weeks this year.
By my calculations next year,
it might be every two weeks
or less.
Five years into the ten-year
plan just 14 projects
are in service of the
promised 10,000 supportive
housing units, the city has
completed fewer than 700.
It would take more than 30
years to house all of the people
currently homeless in
LA County at that pace,
according to a federal court order.
As the homeless population
exploded some shelter providers
implored the mayor to
spend more of the money
on immediate shelter,
mental health services,
and substance abuse treatment.
But Garcetti went all in on
his ambitious ten-year plan.
Los Angeles approach to
the homelessness crisis
is a series of colossal failures.
The city has proven itself
to be incapable of solving
homelessness, but it could
take more modest steps
of helping alleviate,
suffering, and restore peace
and safety to the streets.
It could also bring an end
to many longstanding policies
that caused these men and
women to end up homeless
in the first place.
Los Angeles has the largest unsheltered
homeless population in
America and Ground Zero
is a 50 square block
district known as Skid Row
officially turned into a containment zone
by the city in 1976.
The problem has escalated
into a full blown
humanitarian crisis.
In escaping court order issued
in April Federal District
Judge David Carter called
the city's inaction,
so egregious and the
state so non-functional
that it is strongly likely in violation
of the equal protection clause.
A federal judge calls LA's response
to the homeless crisis, structural racism.
Federal Judge David O. Carter,
he ordered both the
city and county to offer
some form of shelter to the
entire population of Skid Row.
It's a Problem that's rooted in misguided
government policies,
decades in the making,
but Judge Carter's order places
blame for the city's failure
to address the immediate
crisis squarely at the feet
of Mayor Garcetti.
The process of making
good on the mayor's plan
to build 10,000 units
of supportive housing
has been rife with cost overruns delays
and possible corruption.
We have local politicians who are in bed,
who are being investigated by the feds,
our own city council people would,
that's gonna slip the hold on me.
Like what are we doing?
Local public radio affiliate
KCRW has documented instances
of corruption surrounding
the city's homelessness
housing plan with developers
receiving taxpayer money
to build homeless housing,
reselling the properties
to themselves for millions in profit.
Carter notes that the
improper relationship
between City Hall and
real estate developers
is neither isolated nor new.
And that the FBI has been
investigating the possible
corruption in City Hall since 2017,
a probe that has led to the
prosecution of real estate
consultants, political fundraisers,
and even most notably former
council member, Jose Weezer,
whose council district included Skid Row.
In June 2020 Weezer was
arrested by federal agents
for using his position to
cover up illegal activities.
They've said, let's keep the status quo
and allow the developers to continue
because they are carrying
it out in good faith
and they're doing it well.
Well, no, it's not being done well.
It's not being rolled out in
the way that it was promised
and it's not being done in good faith.
Andy Bales runs the Skid Row
based Union Rescue Mission,
which runs entirely on private donations.
He says the organization
shelters more than 900 people
a night and moves more than 900 people
into permanent housing annually.
He's been a fierce critic
of the city's approach,
which she says has been
slow, expensive, and capable
of serving only a fraction
of the homeless population.
I wish I could say I was
shocked at the pushback
from LA County and LA city,
but it's unexplainable.
Federal Judge David O. Carter,
he ordered both the
city and county to offer
some form of shelter to the
entire population of Skid Row.
We're hearing they're evaluating options,
including an appeal.
Judge Carter has ordered
the city to put one billion dollars
in escrow so that he can
monitor how that money is spent.
He's also ordering the
city to provide shelter
for the more than 4,600
people living on the streets
of Skid Row before the end of 2021.
Judge Carter criticized
Garcetti for failing
to declare a state of
emergency, which he says
could have eliminated bureaucratic hurdles
to building new housing.
The mayor has said,
Carter's order will derail
the city's plan.
Stay out of our way.
Roadblocks masquerading as
progress are the last things
we need.
Carter's critics accused
him of overstepping his role
and his aggressive ruling
and an Orange County
homelessness case led
another district judge
to grant several city governments requests
to remove him from their
cases on the grounds
that he's biased.
And the LA city attorney has
appealed Carter's ruling.
LA County is asking to be
dropped from the suit altogether.
This is a deadly status quo
and people don't just die.
They die a horrific death of
assaults, and rapes, and heat,
and cold, and wet, it is
a brutal spiral to death
that we're leaving people in.
I'm a believer in the right to housing,
but at the same time,
you don't have a right
to every park bench.
The city has an obligation to protect
its public right of ways.
If someone is homeless, that is a tragedy
and we need to work on
that and get them into
some form of transitional housing.
But even if city quickly
were to build more
emergency shelters, not
all the men and women
living on the streets of
Skid Row would necessarily
abandon their sidewalk
encampments to go live in them.
I don't wanna live in a shelter
because I might as well just
go back to jail, seriously.
In 2006, a year after a homeless
woman was beaten to death
on the streets of Skid Row,
then Los Angeles Police
Department, Chief Bill Bratton,
launched the safer cities initiative
and sent 50 police officers
to patrol the neighborhood
and issue citations for minor infractions.
Proponents pointed out
that in just a few months,
the number of people
sleeping on the streets
was cut almost in half.
"We've broken the back of
the problem," said Bratton.
But homeless activists said
that many of those people
just dispersed to other parts of the city
and that the city was
criminalizing homelessness.
And the Garcetti administration
ended the program in 2015
when an LAPD officer
fatally shot a homeless man.
I don't think the criminalization side
is reasonable at all.
Once we start incarcerating people
for quality of life issues,
then we've just increased
our costs with the carceral system.
We've re-traumatized people.
And I don't think there's
a moral reason to do that.
The idea that this is
criminalizing homelessness
is an absolute red herring.
It's a total myth that you
can't both be compassionate
and regulate public
spaces at the same time.
Elizabeth Mitchell is
an attorney representing
the LA Alliance for Human Rights.
The group of downtown
business owners, residents,
and homeless people who sued Los Angeles.
She points out that when
judge Carter issued an order
in Orange County allowing city governments
to clear encampments, they
did so without arrests,
by sending social workers to
offer shelter and mental health
and drug and treatment
services and inform those
living there that they had two weeks
to move their belongings from the area.
If you look at this approach
that we are advocating for,
we have sheltered over 4,000 people
without a single citation or arrest.
So I don't see how that could
possibly be criminalization.
Everybody agrees that law
enforcement should be an absolute
last resort, but
regulation of public spaces
needs to occur again for everyone.
There's a danger that law enforcement
could take a more aggressive approach
if the city fails to act.
LA County sheriff Alex Villanova
sent a team of deputies
out to Venice Beach in mid
June without consulting
the city council and vowed
to start clearing encampments
in the coming weeks with
or without city approval.
Several weeks later, the
Los Angeles city council
on July 2nd approved new
prohibitions on camping,
near shelters, parks, elementary schools,
and entrances to homes and businesses.
Literally the only goal
is to get people sheltered
and off of the street as fast as possible
throughout Los Angeles.
What we can't accept is
people dying on the streets
while the city bureaucracies
turnout out overpriced housing
that helps too few.
The suit also argues that the damage done
to downtown residents and
entrepreneurs by the cities
in competence constitutes
a taking of property.
Daisy Suarez, the
proprietor of Desuar day spa
in downtown LA agrees.
We have customers that
refuse to come inside
because they just
completely don't feel safe.
We have customers writing
very negative reviews
saying like, you just gotta
be careful that massage
was amazing, but I would
recommend you go in there
because it's dangerous.
So when we have customers
calling us and saying,
hey, I don't feel safe, I'm
gonna cancel my appointment,
it's just so hard.
Suarez is named in the suit
as is her brother Leandro,
a Navy veteran in a wheelchair
who has often been unable
to navigate around encampments,
blocking sidewalks.
He had a lot of encounters with people
that were aggressive.
People wouldn't move, people
wouldn't give him the path,
obviously tense, and many times
we had to go and rescue him.
The person took out a stick on him
and threatened to hit him.
She also says her two young children
witnessed an attack on her
husband walking around the area,
causing her to move the family 30 minutes
outside of the city.
With the kids in the stroller,
somebody came randomly
hit him from the back
he's on the floor, the kids are screaming,
knocked him down unprovoked.
And after that, I was
like, I gotta get my kids
to safer place this is
not the environment
that I want my kids to grow.
Between 2018 and 2019 violent crimes
perpetrated by homeless suspects increased
22 and a half percent with a 48 percent increase in Skid Row
in downtown LA.
Violent crimes against homeless people
increased 19 percent city-wide
in the same period.
I've seen people get
beat up, run over tents,
being burned on purpose.
I just can't believe what
I see, it's unfathomable.
It's really difficult to watch.
Harry Tadjian is co-owner of
an upholstery supply business
and Skid Row where he says he's
seen conditions deteriorate
on the block outside his building.
After mid 2016, it changed
where the tents did not move.
The tents started getting
bigger and bigger.
Their contents started flowing
from one side of the sidewalk
to the other, and now
well into the streets.
We have vendors that fly
in from all over the world.
They just can't believe what they see.
When they come to Los
Angeles, they're eager to see
the best city in the
world and they see this.
They're just blown away.
And I've never heard once
a customer walk in and say,
yeah, this time it got better.
It's constantly getting worse
and worse and worse and worse.
Both Tadjian and Suarez trace the decline
that began in 2016 to a
federal court injunction,
prohibiting police from seizing property
people are storing on
the sidewalk or street.
What's happened over the last 20 years
is through these series of
decisions and settlements.
That's had a complete
chilling effect on city
and county officials.
Federal court rulings and
settlements have shaped
homeless policy, not only in Los Angeles,
but nationwide with the February, 2021,
Boise V Martin settlement,
making clear that cities
couldn't clear encampments
without offering adequate shelter
a term that's never
been precisely defined.
So the question was by the Alliance,
is there a way that we can use
the courts to do the opposite
to un-handcuff the county of
Los Angeles and the officials
to really do what they
say they want to do,
which will solve this comprehensively?
Mitchell says, Judge
Carter's order gives the city
an opportunity to bypass
this morass of settlements
and begin to move people off the sidewalks
and into temporary shelter.
But instead of embracing that opportunity,
Garcetti has appealed that decision.
The mayor is just kind of
gaslighting us in a way.
I have no respect for the Mayor Garcetti.
I absolutely think that
he is the disgrace.
His usage of funds from HHH
is just unbelievable, ridiculous.
Our city, our county, LA Times
have all pushed back
and fought the judge and
made disingenuous claims
that we can't put a roof
over everybody's heads
in three months.
Well, I can guarantee you if you appeal
and take it to the ninth circuit court
and to the Supreme court.
Yeah, you can't get it
done if you're appealing.
In Judge Carter's report,
he also criticized
Mayor Garcetti for his failure to spend
a significant portion of the
1.2 billion dollars that the city
has borrowed on constructing
temporary shelters
like the sprung structures, tiny houses,
or even 3D printed homes.
The Garcetti administration
claims to have moved
more than 30,000 people
into permanent housing
using existing housing stock.
But the growth of LA is unsheltered.
Homeless population is far outpacing
new housing construction.
It was working with Judge
Carter and hearing a lot
about these tiny homes.
We started doing some research
on them and they seemed like
a good option to add to the mix.
Bob Blumenfield is a city council member
whose district in the San Fernando Valley
has a relatively small homeless population
compared to the rest of LA.
After consulting with judge
Carter, he was able to secure
funding to build 52
tiny homes with 100 beds
in the parking lot behind his office
administered by a nonprofit
that will provide meals,
amenities like laundry,
internet access, storage, drug,
and mental health counseling,
and 24/7 security.
Temporary shelter is costly,
but far cheaper and quicker
to construct than permanent
supportive housing
which is averaging about
550,000 dollars per unit in LA.
The total cost of this cabin
community was 3.1 million dollars
or 31,000 dollars per bed.
The perfect is often
the enemy of the good.
Yes, it would be
wonderful to put everybody
into permanent supportive
housing, that's the goal.
But when you look at the numbers
that is not gonna happen.
We can't tell people that until we have
all the hermit supportive housing,
that it's okay to die on the streets
or to live on the streets
in horrible conditions.
Bloomfield's cabin community model
is based on a similar idea
launched in Riverside County
last year at about a third of
the construction cost per bed.
The ability to have sort of
a door to shut four walls
that surround you being in your own space
I think that was important
to people because your mind
can finally rest.
Tyler Antonin is the program
manager with Citynet,
the nonprofit, the city
contracted with to run the site,
which sits adjacent to a
parking lot less than two miles
from downtown Riverside.
Since launching in March,
2020, the site with 30 units
has served 160 people moving
43 into permanent housing.
You don't know what's
gonna happen on the street.
Coming in here I had my own
place which was a lot bigger
than my tent.
Lisa Care was living on
the streets in a tent
for two years before Citynet
offered her a pallet shelter
and eventually found her an apartment.
She says the privacy and
security offered was enough
to bring her off the street
when often a big group
living shelter wouldn't.
There is no comparison whatsoever.
This place is like living
in one bedroom mansion
or something, as opposed to the shelter.
I'd take my chances on the
street before I go back
to the shelter.
We saw that over 80 percent
indicated that if they had
an opportunity to have their own space,
they would accept shelter.
Whether it might be for
mental health purposes
or just really wanting
that own personal space.
We found that our population was more open
and we're really excited to report
that it has been a success.
Hafsa Kaka is Riverside's
Homeless Solutions officer
and says that while she
believes more permanent
supportive housing is what will
ultimately end homelessness
that transitional options
like pallet shelters
actually help achieve that goal.
It's not one size fits all.
Some of the individuals
who maybe struggled
with getting into permanent
housing were able to find
this as a pathway, filling
out paperwork, document,
ready ID, all of those same
some individuals struggle with.
And so by having the shelter
and the shelter case management,
they're able to get ready
for that step.
There are even lower cost
options used in other cities
like 3D printed homes in
Austin and Mexico City
produced by a startup
for 4,000 dollars in 24 hours.
And in 2016 Reason profiled
a local artist constructing
tiny homes for the homeless
for only 1,200 dollars a piece.
Instead of partnering
with him and offering land
for the homes, the city
seized in a pound at them.
The more than billion dollars
that the city has borrowed
could be used to build shelters like this,
but the city government
has failed to allocate
much of the money to
fast temporary solutions.
But other homeless service
providers and activists
and the editorial board of the LA times
have expressed concern
that judge Carter's order
will derail the plan
to put homeless people
into permanent housing by
prioritizing substandard,
temporary shelters.
Amy Turk points out that while
temporary sites are cheap
to build, they can be expensive to run.
With one parking lot
campground, the city administers
costing more than 2,600 dollars
a month per person.
Can't just set up a
shelter without knowing
how you're going to get
people into permanent housing,
because then people will just
stay in your interim shelter
for a very long time.
It is more costly to run a
shelter with 24 hour staffing
and security, you cannot
look at a place like Skid Row
and think like, "Oh, we don't
need an immediate response."
But we can't at the expense
of perhaps clawing back money
that we've designated
for permanent housing
or not having enough for
the permanent housing side.
Turk is CEO of the
Downtown Women's Center.
Another Skid Row service
provider that helps
homeless women find food
services and housing.
Turk's group has backed
the housing first approach
championed by the city
and owns two buildings
offering permanent supportive
housing in Skid Row.
They found housing for 79
women and 124 children in 2019
according to their annual report.
Turk says the goal should be
to move people experiencing
homelessness into permanent
supportive housing
as Downtown Women's Center
helped Suzette Shaw accomplish.
People living in Skid Row
are living in less than
third world living conditions.
You're always in a state of
survivor mode, whoever you are,
and wherever you came from.
A homeless rights activist,
Shaw has lived on Skid Row
for more than eight years
though she never slept
on the streets instead
living in single occupancy,
hotel rooms, and shelters.
And then the Downtown Women's Center
helped her find a permanent
place in this building.
Having my own home now and
space that I can create
and make that of my own
home and slowly working
to a sense of normalcy.
I closed that door and it's my sanctuary.
You know what I'm saying?
But while Shaw is a notable success story,
LA's homeless population continues to grow
year over year and three
quarters of the city's
homeless remained without shelter.
But we should not leave
this deadly status quo.
All of the housing that
we could possibly do
would be the correct response.
High percentage of LA's
homeless population
has mental illness and
substance abuse problems.
And LA County has concluded
it has fewer than half
the available mental health
beds necessary to serve
as population.
The judge has ordered
directs the city and county
to spend more of the funds
to expand mental health
and substance abuse
services within 90 days.
The substance abuse and
mental health services
are atrocious.
So by requiring the county
to actually treat people
who need treatment, I
mean, it's life-changing.
But there's also a significant
percentage of people
who aren't severely mentally
ill or addicted to drugs
at the time they become homeless,
they might be living at the margin,
pushed out of housing by a
combination of high rents
and inability to navigate
the housing assistance bureaucracy.
The city exacerbated this
problem on Skid Row in the 1950s
and 1960s, by condemning and
demolishing over the course
of a decade, half of the
existing single occupancy hotels
that housed in many of the neighborhoods,
extremely low income residents.
UCLA economist William Yu
is the latest researcher
to find a strong correlation
between high housing prices
and homelessness in a
survey of American cities.
California is home to some
of the least affordable
urban housing markets in the country,
including the LA Metro area,
according to the US census
department's American community survey.
Accounting survey found that
60% of newly homeless people
cite economic hardship
as the leading factor
in their lack of housing.
And that two thirds became homeless
while living in LA County.
The approach of local and state officials
has largely been to promote
measures like rent control
and mandating low cost
housing and new construction.
But market urbanists have
long said that housing
is simply too expensive to
build because of zoning,
permitting an onerous over-regulation.
There's this whole line of thought.
We have a simple supply
and demand problem,
and we need to cut you out of the picture
and just let people build housing.
There's always truth, some
truth and there's always
a little bit of both sides of this.
You know, you just make it
really easy to create supply.
You may end up with just a lot of housing
that's hard to reach.
If there's so much supply,
even the expensive housing
would become cheaper, right?
In theory, but that's often
not what we see in practice.
We see wealthier people
moving to Los Angeles,
and that's also a recipe
for gentrification.
But several studies have
demonstrated that increasing
the housing supply would bring
down the price of housing
for the poor.
A journal of urban economic
study of the bay area
found local land use
regulations are closely linked
to the value of houses sold.
Brookings Institute study of California
found cities with less restrictive zoning
and large populations issued
more multi-family permits.
And a federal reserve
study found that in metros
where demand for housing is high,
more regulations correlated
to almost double the increase
in housing prices.
Even regulation meant to
directly address the problem
by mandating affordable
housing caused prices
to rise two to 3 percent faster
according to a 2009 HUD study.
Since the housing market
structural problems
won't be fixed anytime soon,
the homeless population
is likely to keep growing.
And mayor Garcetti may
be headed out the door
after reportedly being offered
an ambassador ship to India
from the Biden administration.
But his successor will have
to decide whether to continue
on the course he set by
fighting a legal battle
while spending taxpayer
money on six figure
permanent housing units or to shift course
in favor of cheaper,
faster emergency shelter
to more immediately address
the deteriorating conditions
in the city's public spaces.
Judge Carter ordered the city
to offer some form of shelter
for everyone on Skid Row by October.
The ninth circuit court overrode
that order on June 10th,
pending an appeal to be heard on July 7th.
How could anybody be
blind to the suffering?
Really it's all a matter of when people
don't have a roof over their heads.
It becomes very survival of the fittest
it's beyond a disaster
and yet the officials
seem to be allowing it to get worse
rather than intervening.
Judge Carter sees the current situation
as not only a failure of
current city leadership,
but a result of decades of
government neglect and abuse.
Starting with the city
creating and sustaining
the squalor of Skid Row by
making it a containment zone
in 1976, condemning and demolishing
thousands of inexpensive
single room occupancy
hotels using eminent domain
to seize homes in poor communities
for highway construction
and driving up housing prices
through exclusionary zoning
and excessive permitting.
All policies that he says
were designed to segregate
and disenfranchise, the
costs of which had fallen
disproportionately on black
Americans who make up 42 percent
of the homeless population,
despite being only 7 percent of
the city's population.
But you're talking about
400 years of racism
that has contributed to homelessness.
So how do we undo that overnight?
Is the big moral question of our time.
At the heart of this is
really the systemic failures
that are embedded within
our system that have allowed
red lining and the
displacement for Suzette Shaw
and others to no longer exist
in their former communities
and have to come to a
place called Skid Row
because they had no other place to go.
I feel that it's wrong
to criminalize homeless.
Yes, absolutely, but my
staff deserve to feel safe.
My clients deserve to feel safe.
It's not about criminalizing
them, it's about helping them.
The judge's initial order was very fair,
especially towards the homeless population
who need that funding.
It's just not fair for the
city to take their time
and do their process
where it hasn't worked
in the last 10 years.
The mayor has been in
office for eight years
and there's never been a decline
in the homeless population.
How can you say a judge is slowing me down
when we've developed 641 very expensive,
slow to develop units while
5,700 Angelenos have died
on our streets.
The county and the city
appealing the judges ordered
to immediately put a roof
over everybody on Skid Row.
Add that to the record of
corralling and containment
because all that the
city and county are doing
is building the case against themselves
for not wanting to address
homelessness on Skid Row.